let's say we have a hypothetical
reaction where reactant a turns into
products and that the reaction is first
order with respect to a
if the reaction is first order with
respect to reactant a for the rate law
we can write the rate of the reaction is
equal to the rate constant k times the
concentration of a to the first power
we can also write that the rate of the
reaction is equal to the negative of the
change in the concentration of a over
the change in time
by setting both of these equal to each
other and by doing some calculus
including the concept of integration we
arrive at the integrated rate law for a
first order reaction which says that the
natural log of the concentration of a at
some time t is equal to negative kt
where k is the rate constant plus the
natural log of the initial concentration
of a
notice how the integrated rate law has
the form of y is equal to mx plus
b which is the equation for a straight
line
so if we were to graph the natural log
of the concentration of a on the y-axis
let's go ahead and put that in here the
natural log of the concentration of a
and on the x-axis we put the time
we would get a straight line and the
slope of that straight line would be
equal to
negative k so the slope of this line
the slope would be equal to the negative
of the rate constant k
and the y-intercept would be equal to
the natural log of the initial
concentration of a so right where this
line meets the y-axis that point is
equal to the natural log of the initial
concentration of a
the conversion of methyl isonitrile to
acetonitrile is a first order reaction
these two molecules are isomers of each
other let's use the data that's provided
to us in this data table to show that
this conversion is a first order
reaction
since the coefficient in front of methyl
isonitrile is a 1 we can use this form
of the integrated rate law where the
slope is equal to the negative of the
rate constant k
if our balanced equation had a 2 as a
coefficient in front of our reactant we
would have had to include a one-half as
a stoichiometric coefficient
and when we set our two rates equal to
each other now and go through the
calculus instead of getting negative kt
we've got negative two kt
however for our reaction we don't have a
coefficient of
2 we have a coefficient of 1 and
therefore
we can use this form of the integrated
rate law
also notice that this form of the
integrated rate law is in terms of the
concentration
of a but we don't have the concentration
of methyl isonitrile in our data table
we have the pressure of methyl
isonitrile
but pressure is related to concentration
from the ideal gas law so pv is equal to
nrt
if we divide both sides by
v
then we can see that pressure is equal
to n is moles and v is volume so moles
divided by volume would be molarity so
molarity times r times t
and therefore pressure is directly
proportional to concentration and for a
gas it's easier to measure the pressure
than to get the concentration and so
you'll often see data for gases in terms
of the pressure
therefore we can imagine this form of
the integrated rate law as the natural
log of the pressure of our gas at time t
is equal to negative kt plus the natural
log of the initial pressure of the gas
therefore to show that this reaction is
a first order reaction we need to graph
the natural log of the pressure of
methyl isonitrile on the y-axis and time
on the x-axis so we need a new column in
our data table we need to we need to put
in the natural log of the pressure of
methyl isonitrile
so for example when time is equal to
zero the pressure of methyl isonitrile
is 502 torrs so we need to take the
natural log of 502
and the natural log of 502 is equal to
6.6.219
to save time i've gone ahead and filled
in this last column here the natural log
of the pressure of methyl isonitrile
notice what happens as time increases
right as time increases
the pressure of methyl isonitrile
decreases since it's being turned into
acetonitrile
so for our graph we're going to have the
natural log of the pressure of methyl
isonitrile on the y-axis and we're going
to have time in on the x-axis so notice
our first point here when time is equal
to zero seconds
the natural log of the pressure is equal
to
6.219 so let's go down and let's look at
the graph
all right so i've already graphed it
here and we just saw when time is equal
to
zero seconds the first point is equal to
6.219 and here i have the other the
other data points already on the graph
here's the integrated rate law for a
first order reaction and i've put
pressures
in there instead of concentrations
and so we have the natural log of the
pressure of methyl isonitrile on the
y-axis
and we have time on the x-axis
and the slope of this line should be
equal to the negative of the rate
constant k
so there are many ways to find the slope
of this line one way would be to use a
graphing calculator so i used a graphing
calculator and i put in the data from
the data table
and i found that the slope of this line
is equal to
negative 2.08
[Music]
times 10 to the negative fourth
and since if i go ahead and write y is
equal to mx plus b i need to remember to
take the negative of that slope to find
the rate constant k
therefore k is equal to positive 2.08
times 10 to the negative fourth to get
the units for the rate constant we can
remember that slope is equal to change
in y
over change in x
so change in y would be the natural log
of the pressure which has no units unit
and
x the unit is in seconds so we would
have one over seconds for the units for
k
and finally since we got a straight line
when we graphed the natural log of the
pressure versus time we know that this
data is for a first order reaction and
therefore we've proved that the
transformation of methyl isonitrile to
acetonitrile is a first order reaction